one of hottest singers
anywhere the Grammy winner Meghan
Trainor who just released a brand new
song but Meg admitted to our selfish a
lacy that even with her win for Best New
Artist
she still has moments of insecurity
about her body like recently we're doing
a fitting for this music video and I was
like man all these dancers next to me
they're so tiny and I felt insecure
again and my best friend was like you
were all about that bass do not forget
that and I was like you're right I am
hot and I look bomb and these outfits
and I'm a Killa in this video because
you know I'm all about that bass yeah
she's all that but she's also got two
brothers who moved to LA and they're
very protective if I ever do bring a guy
home they're immediately like once they
leave that my brother should like mm-hmm
so that led us right into the rumors
she's dating LA Clippers DeAndre Jordan
there's a certain ball player even
egging that's a great friend oh great
he's the one that texted me like I miss
your brothers like huh we party with him
he's the nicest dude ever he just the
tallest dude in the room really do do it
Sophie met up with Megan at Studio City
sound she's hoping her single no out now
from her upcoming album thank you will
become a dancing we think that's a sure
bet every night like pretending I'm
strangers in the world listening to it
like huh I'm gonna try to girl likes icy
and sassy
yeah she is one of the many reasons we
love you Megan now the video for noah
will be out later this month the megan
said that she's dancing in it more than
she's ever danced in her entire life
every word is like a different dance
move you got this man
you